hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Cola
now I need to make my way back into that
cave but unfortunately I did a dumb and
went out the wrong way so I'm gonna go
back up into this area and hopefully it
won't take me too much longer to loop
back around to where I needed to be
because obviously I should have known it
was all so deathly and horrifying that
obviously that was where I was supposed
to go what is this what is this lead
okay I can't move I can't okay
okay mama I'm not am I supposed to be
dead by a cap all right I can't do
nothin I I don't know what does happen I
can't move I can't move what I can't
even move my compass okay well I'll be
right back I guess cool all right let's
try that again
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to kholat we're gonna
go up into this cave and hopefully it's
not gonna take too long to get back to
where we need to go I need to find out
if that was supposed to happen and if I
was supposed to fall down that or if I
was probably not supposed to do that
okay so if I go down here now hey there
we go that's what was supposed to happen
okay it was supposed to it didn't finish
the animation for some reason I think
maybe because I had my compass out or
something
so I'm alive down here that's a good
good a giggity good thing someone had a
campfire here
oh is this oh this is where I found that
note no that's not where I found things
where am I now I'm just kind of hoping
that it was a shortcut to the other
place that I needed to go cuz it's a
dead end over here alright what else you
got for me what else you got oh hey okay
you got that alright never mind I didn't
think you were gonna be there
sneak around yeah
well that guy had an upset stomach
I'm still funny okay
so we're moving oh okay that's not good
okay all right where's this lead I don't
know what this lead it's just Heidi hold
and not die in or is it a hidey hole
they specifically made the Diane this is
the death hole I went into the death
hole yep the whimpering is started I am
doing okay twenty-one 77217 that can't
be right at all twenty-one
oh my goodness I'm right at the why am I
here why am i crying why am i crying
like a little baboo I didn't even know I
was a girl okay climb back here so here
it's got to be something that I
overlooked yeah where is that rustling
coming from it's not there where is it
Oh here sure where is it oh it's right
there god damn it Wow I could not come
across any trail the tracks came and
went as if someone was playing with as
if the victims were moving and as soon
as I was almost sure I had seen
something and I would find something new
behind the next tree the trail suddenly
went cold I had no idea what was going
on me neither
finally I reached a small meadow there I
found a bound journal as if someone left
it there on purpose the journal belonged
to the members of the expedition they
wrote down their thoughts and
observations note there were also some
obscure entries probably taken down in
the dark concerning the situation they
were in this could shed some new light
on the case hmm I am attaching the
journal to this report we have to
control the conduct of the investigation
and at a certain point stop the
information flow the facts concerning
the incident cannot be made public in
any way shape or form and why is that do
you think is it because the aliens all
of the horrifying aliens with the shadow
bodies and they're probably standing
directly behind me or you miss okay so
either way all right so that was we are
sitting in red I set out at the moment
no no no no so I got all that now I got
that I was supposed to get that before
but again I said I'm a dum-dum I get
distracted by shiny lights and objects I
can't keep my focus on anything I have a
daddy I really do by the way
so now that got that excuse you please
tell me that was creaking of a wooden
nor in this cave and not something
horrifying either way I think I'm gonna
get out of here okay so that was
important that in there was important
but I did it and I'm done with that
oh here whew God this is the area of
lower frame rate I need to upgrade my
computer like nothing against my
computer but it is getting a little old
I probably should set it out to pasture
and retire and get something newer and
sexier like you know computer wise not
talking about anything else so the next
place I need to go is going to be Wow I
didn't know if I'm hey boo boo boo boo
okay so if I'm there might be something
along this route here okay 5461 I guess
it's not be whoa that'd be way down okay
oh it's in the woods here okay so I just
need to go into the woods so follow this
path all the way down there probably
seeing some other horrible thing okay so
I know which way I'm so sick oh so to
follow this path down this way
oh my legs how much fine ow my spleen
I'm okay so I'm supposed to follow this
path as far as I can while giving myself
ample rest because I don't want to be a
dumb dumb and not dude at all so I can
get my who got so pretty I love the
pristine snowy wilderness one of my
biggest like aspirations to do is I
wanna and this sounds like a horrible
idea
I want to backpack across the Russian
wilderness
because the country is so big and the
population is smaller than the United
States but the country is so big that I
have no idea like what what all is out
there I'd probably be shot and killed or
something or die by guns bears how long
I spent suspended it nothing I don't
know what an eon is and then this one
time I pale dim glow
filled it I felt as if some
consciousness started soaking through an
orange cloud into my brain dripping with
heavy drops not letting me pass away
nice and peaceful I fought with myself I
had the strength to open my eyes and
finally after processing the situation
on and on I realized I have no eyes okay
well we don't want to keep talking about
your personal problems let's just get
back to the main thing here Sean Bean
and that is actually I still don't even
know Oh in the forest already I hear a
rissalah oh it's right here okay this
must be the forest already then hello
man see I think hunting we've also
encountered local hospitality when we
were not allowed to enter the railway
station because we were singing too loud
oh good
very warm welcome from the local school
uh-huh we had a bit of time so we met
with the students and told them about
our expedition really when we reached
another station some drunk accused us of
stealing his wallet ah police got
involved but luckily after some
explanations the whole thing got sorted
out huh we spent the whole night in the
Train speaking about love religion
politics but hippies we felt tired we
went to bed but since the compartments
were not closed we decided to keep watch
and switched every couple of hours there
are moments when I doubt whether we are
ready for such a next good not
disturbing thoughts are haunting me
maybe we misjudged our capabilities
others say we'll make it but I'm afraid
I have a bad feeling about this as if a
shadow of fear was breathing down my
neck I cannot explain this it's time to
take a nap it's time to take a nap your
watch is over yeah this is what would
happen if I went out into the Russian
wilderness
speaking of which shout out to all my
Russian fans out there I know there's a
big Russian markiplier community out
there so thank you everybody for
from Russia maybe if I visit you know
how if I'm ever on the ocean for any
reason you know you guys are waiting for
the call of when I eventually fall in
you need to make a huge raft well do the
same thing if I'm in the Russian
wilderness and you see a flare with a
big pink mustache on it form like a
living helicopter and flap it into the
middle of the Russian wilderness and
fine bay cuz I'll be dying of fun and
death okay so I found that note there
oh I'm just supposed to okay I get it so
I can see the forest I'm just not
supposed to leap across this cabin just
yet so there should be still a path down
this way where is the path I don't see
path where's the path I want the path
give me the path oh I get a fork in the
road I'm an idiot
and I'm out of breath cool can that
orange cloud please come kill me that
would be great it's exactly what I need
right now come on down please okay all
right I mean the only reason I will
that weren't no wolf that were an alien
I still don't know if it's all about
aliens I'm glad to know this is in
relation to the thing at all
because the thing is terrifying and
horrible and I don't like that whoa okay
I like this at all
okay
Oh anyway so the Russian wilderness like
the Siberian area of it it's mostly just
inhospitable ice and cold but there's so
much land that's just there and all
frozen and lonely I just find that kind
of appealing I find I find it appealing
being in some place where no one else is
but maybe that's just the introvert in
me
okay thirty nine ninety one thirty nine
ninety one thirty nine ninety one okay
wait no what's thirty-nine wait what how
did I get all the way down here what no
that doesn't make any sense at all I
don't know when that happened alright
whatever the navigation does all messin
with me but there's a pager rustling up
there no I don't even know if I can get
up there right after I think I need to
go around another way to get up there
but there's something about being in a
place where absolutely no one else is
like complete isolation and survival on
your own I mean it'd be very difficult
to do so maybe I should get some
training or have a professional healthy
or maybe we can all like get together
have a meet-up in Russia and then wander
into the woods and we can start a cult
how will that be fun that that tree is
oozing evil that's that's one of them
evil using trees okay but there's a page
at the bottom of it is this this an
alien tree
Lukie okay and these aliens sure do seem
like demons man these symbols of dis a
lien a was sure dazzlings mind is a
curious toy consumed by pain and madness
it resists but defends itself from what
can set it free okay
you mean death the path to understanding
leads through contradiction I'm already
confused and I one simple fact yeah the
fact that humans are the real monsters
and as such we should treat each other
although I had been deluding myself
otherwise for so many years I have
finally figured out my true nature
remember that in the darkness you are
never alone there is always someone who
awaits your fall thanks Sean Bean I'm
pretty sure you wrote that delicious
poem underneath this evil tree that's
how that sounds
that's very bad sounds oh I see you over
there
I see you see you here in the woods just
waiting for me to go over there oh man
that's so cool look at the way the trees
sway
I probably shouldn't just be standing
out here lines coming towards me
I did not realize he was a spotted me
mouki I'll be on my way I'm gonna go
around the tree to see where this leads
holy crap god I cannot run at all oh
that's that's okay I'm gonna I wish I
could run at all
hello please don't
oh god no oh god no oh no hello
at least they're not fast I mean I'm not
fast but at least they're even less uh
okay that guy doesn't need to be fast
I'm running right towards him here badoo
badoo badoo but even even even even even
even he yep okey-dokey
oh into the forest of death Oh Jack me
where I wanted to be great
why was this burned down and how was
this burned down it's oddly quiet in
here and why did this snow stop what it
what the hell went where why it's time
to make any sense what that this the VI
honey what else seven well am i oh no
where I wanna be okay oh god oh god oh
oh oh God ah Jesus Christ okay that's a
good place to stop I guess oh good god
oh oh spasm so hard I hurt myself
alright so I guess I'm done but there's
things all around so thank you everybody
so much for watching check out the
annotation for more scary games that I
played or other cool games I play in the
description below
as always I will see you in the next
video